we're approaching the 24-hour mark dr.
Craig Spencer was taken here to Bellevue
Hospital and put in isolation around
noon yesterday we know that he traveled
to Guinea to treat Ebola patients
alongside the medical charity Doctors
Without Borders he returned about 10
days ago he was monitoring his own
symptoms and officials say he was
feeling sluggish throughout the last
week but it wasn't until yesterday that
is clean that his fever climbed high
enough to alert officials as soon as he
called health officials they acted very
quickly they took him from his apartment
down into down to this hospital in full
hazmat gear they cordon doff his
apartment they have started alerting the
community and they're now passing out
information up near his apartment last
night they also tested his blood quickly
and last night results came back
positive that we did in fact have the
first case of Ebola here in New York
City how about all the things he's done
in places he's been over the last week
what are we seeing happen well we know
that he rode the subway and this was
shortly before he reported his
temperature he rode the subway he
visited a bowling alley he was in an
uber car we've also heard he's been on
runs again he was feeling sluggish
throughout the past week he didn't
develop symptoms until yesterday but
they are trying to track down health
officials are trying to track down
anyone who may have had contact with him
we're being told that his fiancee is
here in quarantine at the hospital and
two others are being closely monitored
as well because of their close contact
with dr. Spencer hey Shelby we know what
officials are doing to try and stop the
spread of this disease what are they
trying what are they doing to try and
stop the the fear the the freak out as
it were because everyone's talking about
not riding an uber happening not going
bowling and not riding the subway I mean
you're really not at risk of getting
this unless you are swapping fluids with
the guy and he's feverish right which
hopefully doesn't happen on this up
right and yes
right and car health officials work on
the wall uber did released a statement
saying the driver and any of any of the
other passengers were not at risk but we
have seen health officials and New York
officials move very quickly they're
trying to be as transparent as possible
posting statements online notifying the
public keeping us updated on what's
happening there they are emphasizing the
fact that people are not really at risk
unless they had close contact as you
said and we've also seen the CDC
dispatch a special Ebola response team
they were on their way last night they
could possibly be here right now and
Bellevue Hospital says they're prepared
they've been practicing they've been
doing drills they were working on fake
patients and you know doing exhaustive
training putting on and taking off their
personal protective gear so everyone
says they're ready but we did talk to
health officials this morning in the
lobby and they said they're definitely
worried they're ready you know there's
no no guarantee this won't spread